well vladimir gutierrez his last outing
very successful throwing his secondary
pitches
here's freddie first pitch home run in
the first inning last night and a ninth
inning base hit
and a missile hit to straight away
center and deep that one right at the
base of the wall at the 404 sign
and freddie freeman with a one-out
double
his ninth double of the year and his
good work tom continues well that ball
was absolutely scorched right on the
button
line drive over the center fielder's
head and said in the open he's been on
the fastball and he was on that one
riley singled walked and scored also
struck out
in the contest yesterday payoff swing of
the miss struck him out
off speed away and riley way out in
front
so gutierrez does work around the one
out double by freeman he's left stranded
at third drew smiley is on a very nice
atlanta roll yeah 4-3 with a 5-11 on the
year coming off a couple of really good
starts his last two times out one ball
one strike for joey votto and the reds
who are 8-4 this year against
left-handed starters the 1-1
in the air toward right center field
acuna says he's got it he does
and that will retire the reds in the
first they get a couple of hits but
don't break through we head to the
second no score guillermo herrera
enjoying a career year
swing and a miss
off balance cut off speed down and away
at bookend k's for gutierrez it is the
top of the third inning ronald acuna
junior
blind drive aquino
great read and makes the play
he killed that ball
ball just to the left of aquino gets an
opportunity to see the angle if that
ball's hit right over his head it makes
it a much more difficult play that was
110 off the back no score bottom of the
third inning two outs bases empty jesse
winker coming up to the plate drew
smiley looking for a one two three
inning
[Applause]
and he just breezed through the reds
order in the third inning he gets winker
to tap back to the mountain and left a
really good start out of drew smiley
contreras is one of the more powerful
rookies he's top 10 at homers among
rookies 2-2
chopped on the ground tough play diving
stop suarez from his knee got him
a brilliant play by a eugenio suarez
slices down any chance for a brave score
oh my goodness gino suarez out of bounds
from the knees no problem that is a
great play perhaps the best defensive
play the reds have enjoyed this year uh
yeah it's just a great great play right
there just fully extended
and then from the knees
runners in scoring position rookie
pitcher on the mound
big series the team is playing well gino
not quite swinging the bat the way he
wants to but d in it up and throwing the
leather good vibes great attitude
tremendous play freddie freeman has been
locked in three days running he smashed
a double to center field in his first a
b tonight
ronald's running pitch in the dirt
they'll have no chance to get it acuna
takes seconds standing up there is steal
number 16.
and now a hit might score you the first
run stolen base reds are much still much
more likely to pitch to freddie so
you're still giving him a chance another
runner in scoring position for the
braves
and hit he does with a line drive to
center aquino going back won't get it
it's over his head it's over the wall on
a bounce and the stolen base turns into
the atlanta run as freddie freeman has a
pair of doubles and the braves strike
first in the fifth inning it's one to
nothing yeah you see there two strikes
they decide to go after freddie they're
trying to throw a fastball
up and away and he threw it right down
the middle
and good thing ronaldo did get that
stolen base or would have been a ground
rule double and second and third so one
nothing atlanta a two out walk a two out
double two out nobody on maybe dansby
swanson can go deep
r del rio as this one's hit toward the
gap in right center field and that one's
going to go
line drive homer for dansby swanson
when he does that that's when he's at
his best and he just extended the lead
two nothing atlanta swanson hits his
13th homer
[Applause]
he has a beautiful swing there
fastball middle away and dansby just
stayed with it drove that ball to right
field
right over the 370 mark in right center
and the braves with single runs in the
fifth and sixth now
enjoy a two-nothing lead
india tags up on a line drive to center
field moves to third base on the steal
now we're a pass ball away from a run
or a base hit stevenson bashes it left
field corner india scores stevenson
turns hustles to second a standing rbi
double and the reds on the board 2-1
or a base hit as you said
we saw stevenson earlier with the runner
in scoring position trying to hit the
ball to right field
you called him snatching the ball down
the left field line just missed the
homer foul down the line
that time runner on third base just
hitting naturally the ball is inside his
ability to pull the ball two on atlanta
dansby's home run the difference that
came
back in the sixth inning
and heredia shoots one towards center
aquino on his horse still going that's
going to carry out and all of a sudden
tom the ballpark is playing a whole lot
smaller i'm guessing the ball is
carrying from right center over because
that one i did not think was going i
knew he hit it good but i did not think
it was going so the braves get that run
right back heredia
has hit number four
and his first since he took john gantt
out here in atlanta june 17th yeah
fastball out over the plate
lead off homer here in the seventh i
mean you love getting that run right
back that you just gave up and atlanta
leads 3-1 luke jackson
enters for the braves to face a eu radio
suarez
suarez unloads high fly deep left center
field hey eugenio suarez
draws the reds within one
a smash to the reds bullpen
well geno did not miss it
you know he hit it high it was just a
question if he hit it long enough
there's your answer right there
[Applause]
that is 16 home runs for suarez he now
has 14 rbis in his last 12 games winker
was all for three tonight all of that
action came against drew smiley
and this ball is cracked to center field
and deep
and heredia with a great catch slams up
against the wall and he's down on the
boarding track
he hauls in the drive from winker and
the braves training staff will hustle
out to see what's ailing him what a
catch to strike the eighth inning wow
look at the dent and the padding
if he's laughing and
saying he's all right i think it was he
had the wind knocked out of him and the
big crowd in cincinnati rightfully so
applauds a great catch so now lefty
lefty last year's mvp freddie freeman
who has two doubles today at rbi but
struck out against hendricks
last time up
will smith had been seen throwing
earlier
deep center naked on the track makes the
catch three scoreless innings from the
reds bullpen will be going for his 16th
save and 17 opportunities he's one and
five with a 382 era outfield deep and
straight away for atlanta
the pitch
swing and a miss at your ball game will
smith nails it down for drew smiley 3-2
is your final score in cincinnati